hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar a physiologically relevant 3d
ecm for in vitro oncology research
and intelligent high content imaging of
3d models i'm susie valdez of lab roots
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by
molecular devices
to learn more visit them at
moleculardevices.com
now we encourage you today to
participate by submitting any questions
you may have during this presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
you might have
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speakers
today elodie
vandenhott a project leader in
pharmacology at
hcs pharma and young
a senior imaging application scientist
at molecular devices
elodea and geom welcome to both of you
you may now begin
your presentation thank you for the nice
introduction and hello everyone
hopefully you can hear me okay um so my
name is dion cruz i work for
molecular devices as an application
scientist for for imaging
and before adobe presents her work at
hcs summer i'm going to
present a few aspects of molecular
devices imaging hardware and software
along with a couple of examples so
we are a provider of instrumentation and
in
right here i'm going to speak about
imaging technology so um
in terms of microscopy and imaging
well we all know what microscopy is
about mostly it's about capturing
a sample with minimal
disruption to the sample itself in
various uh
aspects europe force etc uh
but the difference between uh let's just
say
normal microscopy and automated imaging
is that the
um the the end product
of automated imaging is not so much the
image itself which
you can see on the left and then
different examples of this
in the middle the end products of such
technologies are what you can see on the
right it's about capturing population
data
it's about capturing significant
information
the challenge that we can we can see
as manufacturers is the wide array of
applications that
people wish to run on on those types of
platforms a variety of
samples from the simplest municipal
examples of yeast to multi-organisms
jazeera fish or silicon
for instance and in between everything
in 2d and 3d
with the added holy trinity of
what a solution should be
bringing i which is flexibility
simplicity
and speed all in one in the same package
and to try and tackle the needs from the
different customers that we meet
out in the field molecular devices has
a wide array of imaging capabilities
from the simplest of um of images one of
them be called
the pico on the bottom right here to the
high-end uh micro confocal
uh htai on the top left and the
the aim of today as far as i'm concerned
is mostly to speak about
the high-end bit which is going to be
relevant to what lod is going to show
which is the microconfocal hdr which hdi
that has different characteristics from
a hardware and software standpoint
which i wish to speak about so
this is a console called instrument
and beyond this it can
bring different types of what are called
disks or geometries
so you have a disk start different size
different shape
different spacing of of pinhole types
and what that brings is a great
flexibility in terms of
how you want to that's the performance
of the instrument in the type of i say
that you used to run
not every day you need to use confocal
or high resolution confocal so maybe you
just want to use it as a simple white
field
but maybe at some point you'll be able
to use
you you want to use a a high resolution
confocal disk
and this is available to users with a
simple drop down menu into the
into the software that will allow them
to choose between a given disk or
another one and therefore tailor the
performance of the machine to what they
wish to achieve
we are continuously developing the
offering so we have
two new uh geometries that have been
recently released
uh mostly directed towards 3d imaging
tissue imaging
another feature that that can be
relevant is the type of light source
most recent versions of this instrument
bring
high power channel light sources and but
when i say high power
they are between two and six times more
powerful than
uh the previous generation of
instrumentation that
uh that we propose so obviously using
laser light sources of that nature will
bring
increased signal to noise compared to
led illumination for instance
will allow you to detect uh signals with
uh that's our examples of low signal
uh and and increase data accuracy just
looking at the
very quick comparison um between laser
elimination and led illumination
what that means in practical terms as
well is a two-fold acquisition speed
increase
uh with up to 75 percent lower exposure
times compared to led illumination
you'll have sharper images and also a
wider flexibility with
a channel allowing for multiplexing
another important aspect of those
machines are for instance the
the possibility to use different types
of objectives so you have dry objectives
of
obviously going from 1x200x but
ultimately you also have
immersion objectives water immersion
objectives and that has an impact
um not only as we all understand
when it comes to reducing phototoxicity
and exposure times and increasing uh
resolution because of higher
numerical aperture but it has also
another importance
uh which which is further described here
which is that because you're keeping the
same kind of refractive
index a white a water-based sample
and and what is essentially a uh
the the immersion medium as well from
the objective then you you have an
improved electricity
of your sample compared to dry
objectives or air objectives
that would lead to much more disruption
as to in terms of image quality
um just looking out uh more
broadly probably speaking
there are more hardware options that
exist on on the image express
microphone focal obviously you can have
translated light options allowing you to
do
face contrast imaging you have um life
cell controls with
co2 temperature and humidity if you want
to keep yourself alive for a longer
period of time you have a fluidic module
to do compound addition and medium
exchange
and what we call advanced workflow and
engineering solutions
that to an extent deal with
everything uh regarding automation but
also customization
of instruments so we can provide
solutions that would
meet the particular needs of a customer
if the standard offering doesn't
beat those needs but i'll come back to
some aspects of this a little bit later
looking at a very simple basic
um workflow for cell culture and
compound addition in 3d space
what you can see on the side here is
something that is
uh quite simple quite straightforward uh
the
the simplest way to basically form
things like organoids or ferrous is to
have them
grow or sediment into a round bottom
plate
so such plates are very easy to
uh to image and what you can see on the
on the top right
is for instance on the instrument um
the instrument has acquired the entirety
of a 384 well played
and it's showing to you a montage of all
the thumbnails of all the images that
were acquired in one go so already
at that stage you can see the different
trends
in your plate um with the different
uh sizes of steroids for instance if
you're treating them with with cancer
drugs
um and the number of cells in the
steroids the quantity of life cells
versus death cells which is something
that can quite easily analyze
but not all the situations are that easy
very often you don't have a situation
whereby
you only have a single spirit well what
you
very frequently end up having is a
situation where
you have different objects that are
unevenly spaced across
the well at different heights different
focus levels
different positions in the well and in
order to capture them
selectively we we propose a solution
that's called quick id that is
essentially decomposed in
two steps the first step is is the
acquisition
in low magnification of uh the entirety
of the and then a
quick analysis that will that is that is
customizable by the
by the user will detect uh specifically
the objects of interest
of that particular user and then
um the coordinates of the objects of
interest would be
recorded by the instruments and the
second round of acquisition will only
uh focus on the objects of interest
whose coordinates graph states
previously and that saves a lot of time
in terms of imaging time compared to
having to acquire everything at higher
magnification to start with to capture
all the events
that saves a lot of a lot of images to
store and it's also less time to to
analyze
when you're looking at a slide such as
such as this one
and and the one that that follows
here basically what this is is
summarizing is the fact that
in the first round of acquisition on the
plate an instrument was able to
automatically detect
a number of airway organoids for wealth
and then we'll be able to automatically
come back to those positions of interest
only
then acquire them with in that case a 48
with water immersion
acquire them in 3d with a custom number
of depth planes a custom
custom interval and the custom or
user-defined rather confocal
disk with a laser light source to only
capture in greater detail those objects
of interest
and obviously i spoke about the uh the
quantification so
image capture is interesting but so the
main first micro confocal kind of
still comes with two separate types of
package one of them is called
metaexpress that drives the instrument
that also
will provide a set of toolbox
interfaces to provide some
let's just say classical segmentation
techniques that would be
very open in what they're allowed to do
to the user so in this instance
here what is being shown is just a small
recording of the interface where
the user was able to uh to
quantify in 3d the airway organoid that
previously showed where you have a
quantification of the different cell
types their position in the organoids
different intensities etc that you would
find
for those different objects in the
airway organoid and such an interface
can be used in 2d in 3d of
on data that was required through time
and it can also
deal with other things than than than
organoids but also simple
monolayer cells the other software that
was recently
incorporated and added into into meta
express as well
it's called incarta and that software is
a little bit different and it brings an
added
set of tools that are um articulated
around
machine learning techniques uh either
advanced quality
quantification or deep neural networks
to provide uh
sorry customized segmentation of complex
objects and additionally it also
provides with
the user with advanced 3d volumetrics
calculation and and visualization
going back to this slide i showed
earlier about the
micros the microcontroller hdai
this instrument as i said comes with a
number of features and and
one of them is also the ability to be
customized and also integrated
and before i hand it over to uh to lod
for her talk two final sites
one of them shows these two sides here
are essentially come
from the initial design of the the
automation platform that molecular
devices provided hcs farmer with
that uh dealt with a number of different
steps one of them being the
uh the platform being designed and
represented in in
virtual reality which is what you can
see here and the entire conception
and installation and uh factory
acceptances
site acceptance tests and and biological
method development was done in
collaboration with hcs farm
finish i would like to thank you for
your time and uh
if you have five minutes between two
webinars and
you want to see more don't hesitate to
hop on our website
in the resources section you'll be able
to find a number of videos and webinars
are
pre-recorded and available on demand and
most prominently
a recent imaging workshop that was held
in mid-march
where hcs pharmaceutical and presented
their data as well
and with this i'm going to hand it over
to uh to lod so i just think you need to
take control and
support yours
thanks a lot i will take control so
thanks for the introduction
and of course thanks to uh la boot and
molecular devices
to to uh to organize this this webinar
um i am elod so i'm working in
in hcs pharma company uh as a projected
in pharmacology and
i will going to i'm going to present you
today the
i work on the biominisive relevant
3d extracellular matrix hydro scaffold
for
in vitro research in oncology
first a few words about hcs for my
company
it was founded in 2014. it comes 13
employees
our offices and labs are in loss
near horizonte by your business park in
lille
in france and historically we are
providing services
for the the study of safety and efficacy
of of compounds of ingredients for
molecules in
hca so high content analysis and high
content screening
using 2d and 3d cycle systems
our customers come from the cosmetics
pharmaceutical and nutraceutical
industries
and our company and our president
natalie mubun has
won some awards in particular last year
we were
selected as a deep tech pioneer by a
hello tomorrow global
summit so by ms
is a 3d cycle system we acquire the the
patent
because it is an innovative in vivo
mimicking 3d cycle technology
so we are now concentrating all our
efforts to create a full range of
biomasses products
to answer drug discovery needs research
needs in general
for various organs and therapeutic areas
including
of course oncology because this is the
subject of
today's webinar
so our facilities comprise cell culture
labs
and the chemistry lab for the rnd and
manufacturing of
both biomenis products
we own cell handling and automated
imaging devices
we have one imagexpress micro xls
for molecular devices in standalone
we also have two liquid endless systems
in standalone and two imagexpress
microconfocal imaging systems
on our platform called apix which you
can see on this picture
and also on the one that was presented
by guillaume earlier
knowing that effectively the platform
was was integrated by
molecular devices and if you're
interested in this you
you could you could see uh this
so nowadays still many models are being
being done in 2d cell cultures with
monolayers of cells grown on plastic
and we we know that human tissues in
vivo are in 3d
and with cells being embedded in the
physiological
extracellular metrics with addition
proteins and solid scaffold
behaviors around them and with biomedics
we we know that we can
embed this cells in the physiological
matrix and ecm line matrix
including a solid scaffold part and
addition proteins as well
so we need to reproduce and there is
needing informatica pharmaceutical
industries and
in in academic laboratories any way to
reproduce the individual situation
using 3d cycle system with more relevant
micro environments
a more relevant ecm to develop more
predictive in vitro cellular models
the extracellular matrix is of great
importance in the biology of
of tissues and cells of course
because it is important in cell
anchorage and migration
it is also involved in cell cell
communications
since it is a reservoir for signaling
or signaling molecules like cytokines
and grow factors
the matrix interacts directly with the
cells through uh
receptors and
there is a high impact of the matrix on
the cell behavior in general
in terms of differentiation
proliferation
because it the mechanical force
of the ethium impacted the cell behavior
and also the cell itself impacted the
metrics
because it can produce for example
proteinases that will impact
its structure and composition
the composition of the ecm is different
from one organ or from one tissue to
another
but still there are common components
like structural elements
glycoaminoglycans among them
hyaluronic acid but also proteoglycans
there are also structural proteins uh
collagens
elastin also and last but not least
addition proteins
like fibronectin and laminin that are
important for the adhesion of the cells
to the matrix
the matrix is is also characterized by
its stiffness and there is
in in vivo a large range of different
stiffnesses
uh as measured by uh by the measure of
elastic modulus
that i will i will i will talk to you
about
also a bit later for example when we
grow cells on plastic
we are growing them on on a substrate
that is even more
that is stiffer than the bone and it
makes sense then
to consider the cells in a physiological
matrix that can reproduce
different stiffnesses importantly
the matrix stiffness and also
composition can be changed in pathology
in pathologies like fibrosis and cancer
so uh in our mind it's also really
important to check for
for both features uh composition and
stiffness
uh when when talking about different
pathologies
so the stiffness is critical to generate
the adequate ecm impact on cells and to
obtain representative cell responses
and unlike other 3d faculty systems
biomimicismetrics
stiffness and composition can be
adjusted over a large range to mimic the
the cellular micro microenvironment of
any organ or tissue either
healthy or pathological for example
fibrotic
the hyaluronic acid is a major component
of the extracellular matrix it impacts
the structure of the tissue because it's
important in water
absorption it binds to growth factors
and proteoglycans so it has a biological
impact and the cell matrix interactions
are also at stake i mean there are some
hyaluronic acid receptors at the surface
of the cells
that can in fact impact biological
biologically the cells and uh and
and finally the the cells will be uh
will be um
impacted by by the hyaluronic acid in in
its environment
that is to say biomesis
is at the base of of biomasses products
so it is a hyaluronic acid-based 3d
cycle system
it contains uh hyaluronic acid and
also other proteins like collagen
and or addition proteins or peptides
all of these are cross-linked to using a
peptide
based crosslinker called adh
if you crosslink these components
you get a hydrogel but this one is
unadapted to cellcatcher because it
degrades quickly
so uh it is thanks to a patented process
that you can make all these components
uh create a stable hydroscope for idle
scaffold
meaning we get in the end an
interpenetrated network of hyaluronic
acid and collagen
with a an elastic modulus of stiffness
between 115 kilopascal
and a porosity between 100 and 200
micrometers
is
can you hear me
we're having another little bit of
trouble hearing you again
i'm sorry i see no problem there we go
you're good at the moment yeah okay
so the relatives assist makes uh makes
this matrix stable a long time
so with a stiffness and a composition
that can be uh
adjusted to mimic organ or disease
microenvironment
so i will
move to the next slide so that's why we
call bio-images so hydro scaffold
it is the only 3d cycle system with a
dual
behavior here you see the dehydrated
matrix because it comes um
geofiles it is not only a hydrogel and
not only a solid scaffold
and when we rehydrate the matrix i will
show you
a picture you have both
the solid scaffold behavior with the
fibers that you can see
here on the bright field
picture and also the hydraulic behavior
that is important for swelling and
cell adhesion so this make biomimesis a
unique
hydro scaffold with a dual hydro gel and
soy scaffold behavior
as in fact the one you could expect from
from the native
extracellular matrix
how does it look like under scanning
electron microscopy
biomedici is on on the left so you can
see your whole
matrix here you see it is porous
in fact the cell can easily diffuse
within
and when looking under scanning electron
microscopy more in detail
you can see the hyaluronic acid sheets
here in gray
and in brown the interconnected collagen
fibers on the right you see how
it looks with the cellulite tissue and
you can see the clothes
how close is biomedicine in terms of
ultrastructure
so biomimicis porous it mimics the
in vivo extracellular matrix
and dealing with cancer research we know
that the matrix
is modified i mean the problem is that
at the moment
uh the models do not reproduce the
individual micro environment in
particular the sem
because we know in healthy tissue the
cells are embedded in the healthy ecm
and some changes impact uh this ecm
around the cells
and making the tissue fibrotic or
desmoplastic as it can be said in
oncology field and there is a related
ecm related stress
on the cells then this tissue changes in
use changes
again on the cells may i mean inducing
proliferation
or a migration of the cells making the
cell
more cancerous and the tissue
or metastasis behavior of the cell
so the problem is is that if you do not
model
this in your in vitro model you might
also lose some information
related to the ecm changes so to
properly reproduce cancer
pathophysiology
the cancerous in cm should be taken into
account so composition and stiffness
in addition to the cells
that's uh we have different cycle
products
as i said they have different
composition and stiffnesses depending on
the
on the on the organ or the pathology
and we have uh developed a generic
matrix called bioimages oncology
the generic one in which there is a
hyaluronic acid
and collagen one and then which
composition in in collagen one
and an elastic modulus of one kilopascal
so why have we uh enriched this matrix
with collagen one it's because uh many
cancers
are um in fact um shown to be um
fibrotic cancer tissues are fibrotic
with a high content in collagen one
i will give you examples of cancer cell
cultures and research
that have been obtained in bioenergy's
oncology
and i will show you a couple of results
and pictures
about colon cancer but also breast
cancer later on
i will begin with the ht-29 colon cancer
lines in bioemissis
as seen from this scanning electron
microscopy pictures
you see the growing steroids here within
the matrix so you can see even
interactions between the matrix
and the endospherics themselves here
so colon cancer cells invade the metrics
as as growing
fairways and diamonds allowing
uh to do licensing but also
other immunochemistry
or other techniques you can see easily
the the theories
on the right left picture sorry you see
the matrix here
between the theories and the sphere is
over here
on the right you are able to
to observe a live dead staining of the
cells
the all nuclei are in blue the light
cell are in green
and the dead cells are in red so
biomedicine lose life sustaining the
related image analysis allowing you to
check for example
the anti-cancer drug efficacy of drugs
and this was done uh with with with
conant cancer cells
uh here is the example of five euro
uracil uh
anti-cancer drug efficacy to kill the
cells in vitro
thanks to life that essay we compared
the 2d culture by missus oncology
responses and in vivo
responses you see with the 3d cursor
that we have a low ec50 value
here is the ec50 curve in red and here
in gray in green is the extrapolated in
vivo curve
that we can expect for for this compound
in fact there is a huge gap between 2d
cell culture
and individual responses with biomimesis
oncology we
kind of fill the gap between between
in vivo and the in vitro models so we
are much more
close to we are closer to the individual
responses
in terms of ec50 values
and in c50 curve so this is an example
showing that biomimesis can offer a
better correlation with ibivo data
regarding anti-cancer drug efficacy
interestingly
biomesis allows the long-term culture of
of cancer cells here is again
an example of of a colon cancer line
here it's actu 116 cells
from day three to day 28 in the
biomasses oncology matrix
so the lifestyle calcium positive cells
are in
in in green and below
all nuclei are in in blue you see that
we can
really invade the matrix so you have
ferrite at the beginning but then you
can even get
bigger structures um in the matrix
also showing that this is our live for
all these all this time
it allows there for long-term culture
and something we are
currently working on is the uh is the
use of such long-term models so we know
that we can even go
much further than just 28 days but
interestingly with such model we can
we can do chronic treatments repeated
dose treatments
which is of course interesting in terms
of
of relevance dealing with oncology
treatments
meaning not only an acute treatment but
but regular treatments
another aspect of cancer research is
also the the use of co-cultures
not only the cancer cells are important
in cancer pathophysiology there are also
stroma cells or immune cells that
can impact we know that we can do
co-cultures in biomasses
with fibroblasts cancer associated
fabulous for example and here is uh
are some pictures of of the colon cancer
cells
in co-culture with primary human
microphages
in biomimicry psychology so we know that
we can do such core cultures we can
perform certain cultures
either both cell types different cell
types can be studied at the same time
or sequentially so meaning further
cancer cells and then afterwards the
immune cells or other cells
which give interesting features
for anti-cancer drug testing
in different settings so biomedicine
lost the
use of cultures in in on quality
and um as i said from the beginning we
can play
with biomedicine we can tune biomedical
composition
composition and stiffness and this is
what we have done
but this time in the frame of breast
cancer
we have checked how the modification of
the ecm can
impact the growth of breast cancer cells
yes okay uh so as i said we we take we
we've taken uh bioenergy psychology as
the basis
and um we we changed uh
it's uh it's a stiffness so we increased
a lot so from one kilopascal we obtained
a 10 kilopascal matrix
and in this case we increased a lot the
the proliferation of
of breast cancer cells if we increase
this stiffness to 10 kilopascal but
adding
addition protein laminin in in the mix
then we decreased on the contrary the
proliferation
so given that diamonds composition and
stiffness can be modified
we can easily check for the impact of
any aspects of of the matrix on the
breast cancer cells or other cell types
to in fact go more in the mechanisms
of of risk of cancer pathophysiology
and we can conclude on the effects of
one compound
or another in the ecm
in in the frame of cancer
pathophysiology there are lots of
protein-protein interactions and what
can be
interesting is to uh to check such
interactions using different techniques
i will give you the example today of
proximity legation essay pla
in by humanities so the principle of
biomasses
of a pla issue
is to incubate the samples with uh with
primary antibodies
and pla props uh in fact
just uh for example antibodies that are
linked to oligonucleotides
here a plus and a minus one and if the
two props are close to each other like
around 30 nanometers
which suggests that there is proof that
there is an interaction between the two
proteins
um then there is the ibization step with
a connector oligomers
to complete a dna circle and this dna
circle
serves as the rolling circle
amplification to amplify
in fact the signal and then there is a
realization of a
recently labeled oligonucleotides for
similar detection
so each time you have a spot you can say
that there is an interaction between
two proteins the picture on the right
shows you
all interactions between two individual
proteins
so i cannot give you the names of them
because it is an ongoing study with
our collaborators in mdamp 231 cells
in biomesis so showing that you can
easily check such interactions um even
in
in this in the in this 3d faculty system
uh for this we would like to thank our
collaborator from
the
this great picture
last but not least um so from the
beginning i have shown you many results
in bioimages
in biomimesis matrix in plates meaning
in static
conditions but we have also uh
performed tests in dynamic conditions
meaning
in a biochips here is a
an experiment that was performed in ebd
or
in ebd slice thanks to our collaboration
with
antonique debre from from iemn
showing the the cultures of mcf7 another
breast cancer cell line but more with an
epithelial phenotype
and ndamp 231 cells
with a more mesenchymal phenotype in in
in matrix
but uh that was done in in the biochips
vitamin this can be a can be a
can be adventure justly used in in
biochips
and you can see that the cells after
seven days of culture and the flow
were alive and they show they have shown
different structures
so more like steroids for ms tf7 and
like clusters for mda mb231 but less
organized
in fact we are reproducing what can be
expect
expected from such from such cell lines
in the frame i mean depending on their
features and their phenotype
in in breast cancer
we have tested uh longer time points as
i said here is seven days
but we have uh we have kept them for uh
at least 28 days in in the conditions
we've still the metrics
that can be seen at the end
so we are currently investigating um
the phenotype of the style after a
longer
longer time point of cultures and
it also allows the the study of
specific markers like ky 67
showing specifically the cells that are
in
in in proliferation
we could observe also the cytoskeleton
of
of the cells with actin staining
and the expression of the hyaluronic
acid receptor cd4
uh a long time which is uh
one of the different hyaluronic acid
receptors
that has an important role in in breast
cancer
development so there are different
again um behaviors of the cell lines in
in the matrix and also different
proliferation stages of the south
well this could be quantified using
metaexpress
software at the end of the culture
and this is something we are we are
working on at the moment
uh on the on the features and the
behavior of the conscious cells on long
term
i will finish with this other
application of biomises
namely in vivografting even if this is
something
we are not working on at the moment in
in ethiopia but we know that
bioimages can be uh adventurously
used in in vivo studies
it was done this experiment was
performed with uh hct 116 cells in
biomimesis uh compared to
uh to um to grafting uh
in in mice and the success of
the of the implantation was was really
great it was 100
compared to 63 percent
and with uh less cells from
the beginning of the experiment
on the right you have an idea of how the
the
matrix and the cells were well
integrated in the
off tissues uh you can see the
transition here
uh the good proliferation of the cells
and
apart from the great um
implantation success
i have shown many pictures of microscopy
today but biomedicine
can be used and is compatible
with many downstream analytical
technologies
it is um it can be used for classical
uh spectroscopic plate reader
yes red highly porous so you can
easily take the license of the cells to
make
pcrs or western blots and also elise's
the matrix is biodegradable so you can
finally get the cells
after having degraded the matrix for
flow cytometry so you can get lifestyle
after your culture
and because it is solid it is compatible
with histological techniques
and as i said just in the last slide in
vivlo
in vivografting so biologist is
compatible with main downstream
analytical technologies
so there is no need to change your
workflow
here are the different products that we
are selling for bio images
in different formats 96 well plates but
also 384 well plates
for four screenings and as
explained earlier we can customize
the the mean is this matrix for your
specific
um applications meaning specific
composition of stiffness if you
need a specific component in in the
matrix or a specific elastic module
modulus
and in different specific uh vessel
formats and even specific
feelings of different types of plates if
if necessary last but not least
biomes can also be used in biochips
as i have shown you before
um i will finish with this slide
so by maybe this is the unique hydro
scaffold hydroscaphos reproducing the
extracellular matrix
this is the only system that can
reproduce the stiffness
naturally observed in the various
healthy or pathological tissues organs
because it is it can be done really on
with a really high
range of elastic modulus values
so in terms of pathological tissues or
organs we
we think about cancer but also all the
fibrotic
tissues biomedicine is the long-term
metrics that provide anchor to to the
cancer cells for allowing
a chronic treatment so possibly
repeating those treatments
and biomedicine is composed of purified
well-controlled components allowing
batch to batch consistency
it is suitable for wire circuitry
vessels and is compatible
um with eye contact screening platforms
and
its microscope as the one um
that we are using from molecular devices
of course
so biomessage here is the gap between 3d
psychology system and in vivo
for higher predictability of cancer
models
by reproducing the extracellular matrix
i uh would like to thank all my
colleagues
with whom i am working on biomimicis
and our collaborators who are using
the matrix and provided us with with
some results today
and of course i thank you for your
attention i am now
waiting uh for your questions uh please
if you have questions
even after the webinar we would be glad
to answer uh
about biomedicine with his address and i
would like to i'm sorry for the
sound problems in between i hope you you
now hear me well and that i will
be able to answer to your questions in
good conditions
thank you and thank you so much
aldi and giom for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look it looks like we
already have some great questions
coming in from our audience
our first question is for you geom
is the hardware you have shown for the
htai also available
as an upgrade if i already have an
image express system
uh yes so most of the things for the
question the
as i said we have different types of of
hardware existing and and
we've been proposing automation
instruments and imaging for
for more than a decade now um and so
it has been a primary objective about to
as much as possible provide new
generations
that can be upgraded from uh that can be
obtained from the upgrade of
slightly older generation of instruments
and so it's the case with uh with an
hcai instrument if you have a previously
previously acquired microcontroller that
you can upgrade to an hdi
thank you so much and elodie
this question can the hydro scaffold be
taken
out of the wells and if so how
uh yes in fact um
in maybe it was in one of my
slides on my slider i will just take
the number 29 in fact
you can take out the the matrix from the
from the plate just with a pin set
in fact because contrary to hydrogels it
won't um
[Music]
you you cannot degrade it just like
taking it from the well
so it's quite easy and it's quite
practical if you need to move it
or to do something with it uh so yes
it's really easy
you cannot destroy it by taking it with
inset impact thank you so much
and elodie can you recommend a relevant
3d
in vitro model which can be used to
track
single cells
um i mean it depends on the cell that
you are using
anyway because some of them
will grow in fairways but some other
knots so i i guess it's also
depending on the cells but in
bioluminescence what can be easily done
is you can adjust
just the the density of the cells from
the beginning
you can adjust the density uh in in the
matrix
and we can also play around with with
the porosity so to decrease it
uh and so and so therefore depending on
the cell type and how
it it behave in in the matrix we can
play with different parameters to have
only single cell
i hope i answered the question is that
true you could hear me one
thank you so much now
for both of you could the 3d
extracurricular matrix
explained oncology disease clinically
especially for medical
practice
um could the physics of symmetric system
oncology disease clinically especially
for medical practice
i'm not sure i get
what is meant by medical practice
but as far as i know
since we can keep the cells for a long
time and as i said we can do chronic
treatments repeatedly treatment and even
with
with biochips we have uh in
collaboration
again observed great results in
pancreatic disease
um in terms of of responses that were
clinically relevant
so if it's in terms of responses
or long-term long-term studies um
i would say yes if it's in terms of
pathophysiology
um i would say yes again
but depending on which mattress you use
and which cells you use for example if
you mean
medical practice and the use of cancer
cells from patients i haven't put any
data here today but but we know that
that this can be done with also primary
cells from patients
so this is also something we are we are
working on in the
at the moment thank you so much and
again i want to thank our audience for
these great questions
coming in our next audience question is
when we grow cancer cell lines in bio
nemesis
in fact yes most of the results i've
shown
today were done with cancer lines
so i mean i cannot be exhaustive
but we have tested really a lot of style
of cancer cell lines in bioluminescence
oncology so yeah definitely yes
thank you so much and our next audience
member says thank you this is an amazing
webinar very informative what are the
difficulties that you have
encountered when cold culturing
tumor cells
culturing um so
when us what problem have we encountered
we're culturing
two muscles i mean i we have i
encountered most
problems uh in 2d i've been crowded
wells and
but um in the matrix um
we can we we could adjust really easily
the
the the density of the cells
and um really it's really difficult for
me to answer this question
um maybe that it works
really great um so you need to adjust
the density of the cells
because
you it depends on how long you need to
cultivate the cells
because then you you might need to
change the format uh to have enough
circulation medium to feed all these
growing cells
yeah that's that uh that is something uh
you should
be careful about when culturing uh
cancer cells in general
in 3d um if they are growing well uh yes
you need to feed them really regularly
or to change the format but this is
something easy again with biomimicistic
and you can change
from one format to another so
thank you so much our next question is
for you geom
you mentioned other imaging platforms
such as the pico express
if htai is meant for high-end 3d
imaging are those also meant for complex
3d biology or other types of assays
so thank you so i guess it would it
would depends what you mean by by
complex
in the in the 3d space um
certainly you can use the picot the pico
is a much simpler instrument
it's a it's a wide field
benchtop personal imager uh and in these
respects
it lacks the the the actual resolution
that the confocal machine such as the
micro would bring
but it still allows you for instance to
look at simple
models such as just ferroids you can
follow steroid size and intensity
through time which is fine uh you can
look at uh
abstract structures in 3d but you will
not get the same kind of information
that you get from a from a compoco
instrument in general those machines
can be found in labs that have nothing
to do with pde for instance because they
will just
use them on 2d monolayer cells
on a wide variety of i say in 3d space
you would find them in for instance in
asset development
in early stages of screens
to do some very simple testing before
you go on to the big machines and do
more advanced screening so you can
definitely use them in 3d space
with less resolution with the confocal
machines
but they still bring some relevant
information there you so much dion
our next question is for you elodie is
there
heparin sulfate in the composition of
biomimesis thank you um
so in the basic um
i mean basal composition of biomasses uh
no but um
[Music]
i know that we can add for example um
controversies called protoblacken and
others and i do not see any problem to
add apparently fat
uh in in the model um i mean in the
matrix if
if if it should be done as soon as we
can find the component
uh anywhere you we can add it to the to
the metrics in fact
thank you so much and here's another
question for you
and our final question for our webinar
odi is there an expiration date for this
product
um yes but it's uh it's uh
it's not short so you have one year uh
expiration date um meaning if you
if you get the plate you can use it uh
within a year
i mean if you keep it in the fridge and
it is sent in in sealed packages
um yesterday it's quite long it's even
really long for for such a product or
one year
in the fridge and it's it's it's still
uh it's still really um
in good conditions to to be useful to
this culture
dion elodie thank you so much for your
presentation today
would you like to provide some closing
remarks for our audience before we go
i'll start with you laurie
um yeah i just wanted to
tweet that's it's
and actually i'm going to move to geom
because we lost you again elodie
jim would you like to provide our
audience with some closing remarks
before we go
uh yes well thank you to thee and thank
you um for uh your uh
the organization of this webinar and
thank you for the to the audience as
well uh just going back to the um
to one of the questions about the uh the
use of those models
uh in uh in the clinical space
uh i guess what we showed today with
zero demo was mostly r d and not
that close to the clinical space but we
as a provider of molecular devices we've
seen
definitely a complexification of assays
over the last few
years moving from 2d monolayer onto
3d space steroids organoids
microfluidics
etc uh as end points or even in
in
in time lapse or through time
and this kind of complexification of
assays is really allowed by
an increasing maturity of both the
hardware and the software packages that
are coming with instrumentation
or indeed the type of models and
products
like biomimics that lod proposed and the
um you combine such maturity with the uh
the statistical the physiological
relevance of the model
the appeal the multiplexing of
microscopy techniques
uh and uh the statistically significant
data the population data that is
provided with by automation
this makes it a great uh combination
biometrics and automated imaging
uh to to provide um data
information that are as physiologically
relevant
as possible within the confines of a of
what is essentially an individual model
and and um and to that respect we know
from
from a variety of customers that this is
used in uh
in let's just say translational medicine
uh quite increasingly uh
to to to get insights into into cancer
research
uh in particular so um
if if you wanna if you're working on a
particular cellular module
and and um and
if you're interested in knowing more
it's always a about how those
technologies and techniques are always
are used to
you know just turn towards pubmed or
google scholar and have a quick
bio research because you you'll find
a lot of a lot of articles a lot of
papers that have been published
uh using those technologies um yes these
are my concluding remarks thank you
everybody
everyone for attending thank you i'm
sorry that that you lost me again but uh
and no worries and thank you hello to
eugene for your time today and for your
important research
i'd also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor molecular devices for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab which will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
bye bye